well this was my film school all right
and this was the best film School a
person could possibly have I mean I
actually instead of like going to school
and paying a ton of money to be allowed
to use some of their crappy equipment
all right I actually went out and
actually tried to make make a feature
film around 22 23 I said well you know
what I'm gonna make a film yeah right I
had actually met a few different
directors by saying I was going to write
a book and wanted to interview them all
right and so I ended up like talking to
them and they all said that they had
made their first films by the time they
were 30. so I thought well okay well I'm
going to beat that I'm gonna make my
first home with 726. so I ended up
working for like three years on this
movie and this was going to be my
feature and I was like and was financing
it from working at a video store so what
means was like I would like get like 200
or so and then we'd go off and shoot for
the weekend all right now I failed it
was guitar picks when I was finished but
when I looked at the footage now all the
stuff I did the first year which was all
the story stuff all right sucked all
right but the stuff that I did like the
last couple of months yeah that wasn't
so bad